good morning Hank it's Friday so today's
video was going to be about this
nerdfighter gathering on Sunday at 5
p.m. in Chicago before the beckoning of
lovely thing more info up there if
you're interested and about how people
with social anxiety who choose to spend
all of their time in a basement writing
stories and talking into a video camera
can sometimes be very uncomfortable with
hugging and pictures and stuff but then
because we gave in the mail because we
gave in the mail did you guess that it's
the gigantic picture the last words of
favorite people because I'm shy in real
life but when I'm in my basement alone
with the video camera on I sometimes
geek out that's right Hank someone has
written a 671 page book containing more
than 3000 people's last words Hank as
you know the narrator of Looking for
Alaska my first book is obsessed with
the last words of famous people and
obsession I share in fact I don't want
to brag but I mentioned in this book
rabble is last words took on wider
popularity and discussion when they were
prominently used in John Green's 2006
Prince award-winning novel Looking for
Alaska I mean Hank this book contains
all the last words I've never known but
wanted to know like the actor Douglas
Fairbanks he was asked how he was
feeling and his last words were I've
never felt better and Hank I've always
wanted to know William Faulkner's last
words the brilliant southern novelist
who I grew up admiring so much it turns
out his last words aren't famous because
they're boring he said yes Jim I will to
his brother-in-law in a conversation
about getting picked up from the
hospital right terrible last words but
father did write the best resignation
letter ever he resigned from the United
States Postal Service in 1924 and I
swear I'm not making this up with the
following letter as long as I live under
the capitalistic system I expect to be
influenced by the demands of money to
people but I will be damned if I propose
to be at the beck and call of every
itinerant scoundrel who has two cents to
invest in a postage stamp this sir is my
resignation signed William boss Faulkner
Ben Franklin's last words a dying man
can do nothing easy the British composer
John field when asked whether he was a
Catholic or a Calvinist said I'm a
pianist the last words of American
president Millard Fillmore which I
quoted in Looking for Alaska as being
the nourishment is palatable where in
fact the nourishment is palpable the
physicist Richard Feynman this dying is
boring department store owner Marshall
Field's the second what are my chances
of recovery doctor I mean in retrospect
zero the poet Robert Frost
I
feel as though I were in my last hours
and that's just the selection from the
F's Hank there are 25 other letters
represented in this remarkable
collection of the last words of famous
people I'm not gonna lie to you Hank
last night I stayed up till 3:00 in the
morning reading this I mean don't get me
wrong Hank I enjoyed the Hunger Games
trilogy but did it keep me on the edge
of my seat like last words of notable
people no way Sarah kept saying turn off
the light and I would be like Sarah do
you know the last words of Archimedes
were wait until I finished my problem
okay I'm gonna go back to reading
because I just got to the Gees and I
can't wait to find out what Curtis last
words work but nerdfighters I do have a
question for you on the topic of what
this video was going to be about have
you ever met Hank or me in real life and
if so please give me an honest appraisal
of that experience like were you
disappointed that in real life we are so
poorly edited or was our general
weirdness kind of off-putting or did you
have fun and you would do it again let
us know III actually I skipped ahead and
I found a last words of Goethe he said
more light Hank I'll see on Monday